après dragon mais en dessous programme
pour le guen d'argent ouais je crois
qu'il ya 1500 euros en jeu mais bon
c'est pas rien quand tu regardes
l'extérieur tu te dis pas pareil
appareil que le tennis quoi tu te dis
pas je vais suivre le match de madrid a
fait part aux demi finales contre 6
passes et tapas le prize pool en tête
ça a commencé ça vient juste de
commencer alors du coup bénéficié qui a
joué deux des quatre des cinq cavaliers
trois des cinq et d4 ok donc déjà si
c'était dans l'optique de jouer une
benoni des 5 c'est une grosse erreur
parce que ça transpose dans un gambit
dame
donc en fait juste un petit conseil
comme je sais que sardou la benoni
normalement plutôt cavaliers fils dans
ces cas là et comme ça on peut re
transposer suivant ce qui se passe
dehors sur des cats à transpose dans des
quatre cavaliers f6 cavalière 3 en
jouant des cinq ans fait ça retombe fait
ça retombe dans une slave qui est une
bonne ouverture alors il ya des princes
et 4 qui est pas mal surtout g5 et qui
est déjà avantage noir mais mais c'est
juste un autre répertoire donc il faut
être un peu malin sur cavaliers f3
hockey et donc
a dépensé 4 ça prenait un avantage
direct ça faisait 5 6
du coup ça enferme le fou ces 8es c'est
une mauvaise variante de la slave ice
la même chose il faut commencer par
cavalier à 6 ans fait pour
pour obtenir la bonne position site
suivant ton répertoire mais surtout pas
mettre le pied en d5 ce n'était pas un
jour de d4 d5 ça c'est hyper important
sinon t'as tout après pas qu'ils tombent
à l'eau mais
la position est correct alors le
problème cette position là c'est le fou
c'est 8
il faut libérer soit en réussissant à
jouer eux cinq donc qui peut être un
cours préparés par cavalli b 17 tours 8
fou des six mais j'ai rarement ça marche
pas soit il va falloir faire plus on
prend ces quatre des cinq fours baissait
depuis ces 5 et le truc le plus
classique dans les slaves alors là il se
trouve que c'est pas forcément la
meilleure variante mais en gros et c'est
ça soit on réussit à jouer cinq et on
passe sur cette diagonale soit on la
joue avec b6 fou bessette soit on la
joue avec qui on prend des 5 fu bessette
des cats et 5 qui envahirent le plus
classique ou puis on prend qui on prend
des cinq à six fours bessette ces cinq à
six si si ça peut être une bonne idée si
c'est dans l'idée de jouer avec qui on
prend fou prendre des cinq poubelles
cette c5
du coup quand on fait à 6 les blancs ça
leur donne la possibilité éventuellement
de jouer ces 5
parce que quand on va pousser b on
pourra prendre et créer une caste faible
en c5
du coup ça peut devenir une idée
il fait b3 leurs baies 3 c'est pas mal
mais quand il ya le fou ici pour faire
flamber deux sinon ça fait pas
énormément sens mais ok ça fait quand
même le sens de sur des ces jouets
baissé ça ça peut aller acheter ça pose
une question
alors ok je vais peut-être des cinq du
coût pour
on prend qui on prend essayé après de
faire flamber cet écart va lieu 4 qui
est une idée
1 co 6 pour fou b4 pour mettre la
pression sur le cavalier je pense pas
que ça marche ici mais ça peut être un
plan qui on prend et c5 peut aussi être
une idée mais en gros c'est tout le
thème ça va être enfin quand on dit
pampilles on prend un essai 5 c'est avec
l'idée après de jouer b6 fou bessette
tout le truc c'est qu'il faut absolument
développer le fou ces huit salles truc
donc
b 5 c'est plutôt un coup correct dans
l'idée après après pions prend pions
prend le fou a quand même resté enfermé
mais bon à ce niveau et les blancs
peuvent jouer colonnes c'est massimo là
je pense que c'est très dur à voir et
surtout que sur pions prend peut-être
essayé je prends mes joues avec la
faiblesse ans et six en c6 mais libéré
le fou et sur ses preuves et 5 on peut
reprendre de a
il reste aussi ses cinq comme option
pour tous fermés mais quand on fait ces
cinq femmes souvent l'optique de jouer
dames c'est cette es15
donc ça va
ce qui marche pour
certes c'est une slave salissez
différence de niveau est là sinon moi je
trouve pas la slave c'est bien ça dure
ça fait des fautes ans il ya quand même
1200 il est quoi les 1200 rap je regarde
quand même le classement beats 1040 en
blitz
ok on a vu en ce battle 1 c'est pas ça
ça donne en a encore un tu as heard et
quand même beaucoup plus fort bond en
blitz non mais en rapide c'est quand
même 200 points normalement 1000 il
donne encore beaucoup un deux pièces en
or on le voit vraiment ce battle qui
fait ces cinq après ce qui est juste
dommage sur cavalière 3 d'avoir commencé
par des 5
c'est juste ça en fait qui est dommage
c'est de se retrouver dans une position
à mes bons amis jouent le système de
londres en fait avec les blancs ça fait
qui peut comprendre cette position par
symétrie après
gardez le fond ces huit c'est pas très
bon costes kf3 bah si son répertoire
celle à benoni l'obliger à jouer
cavalier à 6,6 peut pas faire des 5
ça fait aucun sens en fait tu peux pas
en fait c'est juste un répertoire pas
cohérent ça pas de cohérence en fait
mais ça va à la position truc c'est que
ça ressemble à ça ressemble au london à
l'envers et ça ressemble aux cavaliers 4
quoi donc ça va bien se passer et
simplement il ya le fou c'est 8 qui
enfermés mais e5 ça va arriver
les blancs ont assez mal joué donc ça va
aller
ça va aller normalement il
voir rue simcoe qui va partir et ça va
donner
voir un homme
le 5-1 et c'est cool parce que c'est un
risque
si on prend 4 en fait tu peux faire fou
prend puis on prend qui a aidé de f 5
puis e5 est libéré le fou donc non ça va
ça va la position est plutôt correct
pour les noirs après il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses hein la chance il va
jouer au f5 et e5 est ce que ça
ressemble au plan de pillsbury qu'il
aime bien normalement il va faire ça
après je pense que cinq effort aussi
direct ça va libérer le fou et les
normes plus qu'égaliser ok cavaliers
affichent 6 du coup ça règle pas le
problème du fou ça c'est vraiment
important
5 du coup pour libérer le fossé vite
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment hyper
important cavalli f6 le problème c'est
que ça donne la case 5 et ça permet pas
de sortir le fou c'est le truc à
comprendre dans ses positions là en fait
c'est que si tu règle ce problème la
tuque a égalisé tant que le fouet
derrière les pions tap a égalisé et là
ils avaient vraiment l'occasion de faire
re 5
pas sûr que
le truc c'est que c'est pas vraiment à
voir pour les blancs parce qu'il empêche
naturellement le 5 fait c'est jusque là
le coût pour les noirs ces cavaliers 17
pour jouer le 5 mai gère que les blancs
ils ont toléré depuis le début bon déjà
il a fait bouger 5 et grosses fautes ya
des princes et 4 mais peu importe en
fait quand il a fait ses 5 il n'a pas
faim il sait pas du tout mis en place
pour empêcher 5
donc ça se voit qui connaît pas le plan
je veux tu penses tu es noir sont
gagnants audonien bas dans le hockey les
blancs sont peu mieux mais ce niveau là
c'est vraiment pas une grand chose en
principe emprise pré carré les bains
l'asim est en fait à ce moment là tu
pouvais faire 5 libéré ton fou
c'est mon coup b4 qu'avait laissé 3 ça
peut être une idée mais l'idée c'est
surtout x 6 quand tu fais ça parce que
lecavalier en c3 ici va rien faire en
fait il va être décoratifs alors que le
carélien au sein qui va taper mes supers
dame s'est cette fois ci c'est changer
de fou de cases blanches ça va aller
la position va donc
il ya eu 5
qu'at il
am c'est cette fois ci ça va elle
cavaliers en c3 ça va ça va je suis pas
du tout inquiet là
sont plutôt stratégique on a juste fait
l'erreur du fou tu peux pas
le pion à c'est une attaque en un moment
c'est pas une partie tactique n'y avait
pas de grosse erreur à faire les deux
joueurs ont pas vraiment compris le plan
des noirs du coup ça s'est équilibré fou
bessède ça défend et ce genre de
position vraiment très dur à ce niveau
là même même si les blancs sont mieux
c'est même
il joue mieux ca c'est vraiment
cavalier c3s qui serait bref le truc
c'est que dams et de et où il va avoir
une pression via le foot le foot case
blanche ce qui serait vraiment très
important c'est de voir le x 600 fait
cette comprendre que ce fou sert à rien
de mettre une dame ans et 7 pour
protéger de dégager sous deux cases
blanches qui peut être un problème à
terme
ça va à l'autre le voit peut-être pas
mais là vraiment ça et ça ou cavaliers
17 pour quand même essayé de pousser au
5 ça peut être un plan ça doit aller un
client en fait j'aurais pas perdre cette
position avec les u17 bien joué j'aurais
vraiment pas peur cavaliers prend et e5
on peut servir fou on peut pas s'en
servir du fou même s'il est blanc ouvre
parce qu'il sera bloquée par le pion c6
et genre tu peux avoir une varangue ça
pour être qu'il y ait des sept prix ça
c'est pas les coûts de la partie mais ça
ça pourrait être une idée pour les
blancs d'essayer de maintenir une petite
pression mais les noirs aurait eu cinq
ici il réussira à sortir leur fou donc y
aurait pas de problème si les blancs
réussi c'est ici à faire un truc comme
f4 bon ça irait quand même en et dams et
huit fois sis au pire je pense ça va
tout le temps pour les noirs je vais
mettre une petite et val-d'or dit mais
je suis pas du tout mis lors dit depuis
le début
mais je pense à ça c'est qu'il prend au
5d prend 1,5 à vannes en plus adam
français 5
ouais ça cavale yeux de cavalia 2
c'était vraiment qui est recalé prend
décès d'un premier set carré lieu deux
camps même hockey prend deux dames 3e 2
qui est pro 5 puis on prend 1,5
ok c'est pas si mal joué puisque puis on
prend 1,5 qui va pouvoir jouer avec 4,4
et maintenir ce fou enfermé moi
j'aimerais bien jouer en co etc et noir
comme dame c'est cette attaque le pion
au f4 dame ces 8es fois ci ça j'aurais
vraiment envie de me débarrasser de ce
fou rapidement c'est le
la position c se fout toujours je le
répète mais parce que c'est primordial
de le comprendre et d'un bep deux dames
des quatre f4 et f5 ça c'est vraiment le
genre d'idées pour les blancs f4 g4 pour
ces deux une fois que la dame est en des
quatre tours j'ai 2 3h un tour j'ai un
f5 vous voyez souvent joué des positions
comme ça avec les blancs et faut surtout
pas faut surtout pas regarder ce fou
bessette quoi ça c'est la cata c'est
vraiment
ap à ce que f6 marche peut-être caf si
c'est un coup même fin de même si on
fait ça en fait ça ça peut vraiment
aller pour les noirs mais on voit le fou
qui tapait l'autre fou qui tape pas on
voit la différence des fous tour à cette
f4 on voit la différence n'est pas si
ces visuels pour vous c'est hyper
important de le comprendre en fait
ok si c'est pour faire fois ci c'est
bien joué et du coup les blancs auraient
dû anticiper le truc et faire dam des
deux tours f2 pour avoir fouillé ici
c'est pour ça que j zeddam b2 c'était
pour réussir sur tours à huit fait je
leur montrais tour à cette dame b deux
tours à huit tours f deux fois six fours
b1
on échange on laisse pas les fous c'est
changer on laisse se fout là sur la
diagonale du vide et après on va
attaquer bon après f4
un plan là ça peut aussi être une idée
hein c'est pas idiot ce qui fait
commencer quel est le bon foobar garde
en fait tu regardes la couleur des pions
centraux si tu regardes les quatre pions
sont trop ils sont sur noir donc le bon
fout des blancs c'est le fou de cases
blanches et tu regardes les pions
centraux des noirs ils sont sûrs case
blanche donc le four deux cases blanches
il fait double emploi et donc c'est
l'autre mais de façon on voit bien qu il
y en a un qui t'a beaucoup n'osent pas
trop donc f5 tourcoing f5 et maintenant
la question c'est est ce qu'on a le
temps pour x 6 avec les noirs si on a le
temps pour fois ci ça va aya peut-être
même fou ces 8es dame prend 1,5 ou g6 et
prise 5
ok ça peut passer f4 f5
c'était trop hâtif fallait faire le dam
des dos d'âne des 4 et après préparer
envoyé raté de la part de benji donc la
maintenance + 5 va gagner et du coup
tous les toute la stratégie dont on a
parlé avant elle va elle va être
détruite par la combinaison tactique et
dames g4 d'alger chat sache s'en aille a
poussé 8 juste pardon ça sentait le h5
en fait il a juste poussé 8 il ya
immédiatement
ça joue bien ce soir
ouais mais l'après f4 f5 c'est grave
mais oui ça joue mieux et tous rêvent
trois dames 35 et du coup ça retourne la
partie souvent ce qui se passe en fait
aux échecs tant qu'on n'a pas un certain
niveau c'est que la tactique est très
importante
c'est pour ça qu'on vous dit souvent de
travailler votre tactique parce qu'en
fait la stratégiquement les blancs
plutôt dominé la partie mais il a fait
une faute tactique et en fait ça
retourne tout le jeu stratégique d'avant
c'est pour ça que c'est si important
d'être bonne tactique
c'est tout l'intérêt
tactique afu pranger 6 tactics et les
opportunités en 1 là par exemple où
pranger si sûr puis on prend les sisters
point f8 ça retourne de nouveau la
partie mais normalement il va pas le
voir parce qu'à 1200 il doit pas avoir
ce genre de trucs normalement il doit
pas avoir un truc comme franges et 6 et
donc ça passe à 1200 non tu as même à
1400 et que noir ça se voit pas assis là
vu qu'elle n'aurait pas dit
bâle a du coup la partie retourner parce
qu'on est deux nouveaux comme il ya une
échange d'erreurs tactiques à peu près
de la même valeur
on est deux nouveaux avec mauvais fou
contre bons fous il faut de nouveau
faire x 6 pour faire une enfilade
provoqué food est roi fou prend des
trois dames prend des 3 et essayer de
mettre le roi à l'abri peut-être avec un
coup comme f
je voulais faire f 6 pour essayer de
ramener la tour en g7 mais adam g6 d'un
match 6 mais on va essayer de blindés
avec les tours donc il faut à 6 et bien
joué ça fait une enfilade adversaire
doit absolument voir foot est roi mais
fois ci c'est le bon coup pour échanger
les pièces
difficulté c'est que le roi noir est
plus ouvert parce qu'il lui manque le
pion j'ai donc c'est clairement un
avantage ben maimon benji fichiers mal
autant moi je la sens bien cette partie
je pense un peu plus fort tactiquement
et du coup il devrait l'emporter
ouais ça allait plutôt bons mots ne peut
en fin de partie puis la route fait pas
fou des trois ans quand il a peut-être
pas vu en fait il va peut-être faire
juste dames c'est de laisser la qualité
en l'air et basta on dit tout
voire peut-être je sais pas je me rends
pas compte
il faut désormais
évident mais bon après
il a pas vu ce que je disais à 1210
l'agencé qui verrait pas fou pranger ici
s'il a pas vus food étroit du rhin à ce
niveau là bas on le voit on se bat alors
c'est l'équivalent de 2000 ans que je
vous disais en blitz
c'est l'équivalent de 1000 à peu près en
humiliant entre fait l'étude cette
battle ça rate un des choses comme ça ça
rate
genre de choses donc là ça a gagné
la qualité mais ce n'est pas encore fini
c'est dingue qui va
attaque fait je me bats non
fait maintenant c'est pas dingue en fait
c'est comme ça enfin juste faut le
savoir
ok
mme allemand il doit bouger son fou mais
ce qui va avoir comme un an pions prend
menace parce que la tour est protégée
c'est pas sur 1
je sais pas s'il va voir je pense qu'il
faudrait que remettre une cadence de 3 +
0 serait plus marrant au moins ça
enverrait qu'avance of battles c'est un
peu long quand même faut h5 normalement
fallait remettre le fou sur sa diagonale
pourra jouer pour dames f5 et les cases
blanches s'est pas encore
à nier mais tu attends b1 là il ya
peut-être dame prendre dame prend faut
faire gaffe ça peux tu peux te prendre
congé trois dames m6 ça peut être mat
très vite me prend
être dangereux normalement je pense que
tu dois vouloir cacher ton droit mais
c'est pas si simple avec les noirs
encore bref ces deux c'était juste
tellement machiavélique sur dame
français 5 je pense qu'ils avaient tout
rejet trois rois mages suite d'un bref
si ce matin c'était hyper machiavélique
winneway c'est bof je pense pas je pense
que c'est trop tactique
honnêtement mais c'est vrai qu'il n'y a
pas de coups évident pour les noirs je
pense un coup comme dame 5 est bien ici
juste centralisation et blindage
mais c'est pas un coup facile à jouer je
regarde les coups les plus simples
mesdames 5 ça va maintenant beaucoup
jordan g5 ce hoquet dame c5
ça peut marcher
la belgique doit être dégoûté de pas
avoir fait pousser 2 mai au kenya pas
tour j'ai trois rois ici d'un f 5 roy
keane ans mais c'est ma tante 3 en fait
j ça peut marcher mais en fait c'est ma
direct sur watch cette dame et sa dame
m6 dame g7 matt bryant dame cinq joyeux
c'est un piège je n'avais pas le mode
direct nom est terrible terrible sa
santé qui avait pas de coups simples
évidences ces dames cette dame 5 le coût
pour blinder
mais ce n'est pas un coup facile ouais
à quoi la partie va être tactiquement
c'était bien mais avait le problème du
foot cases blanches en fait qu'il
restait un problème trop longtemps et du
coup c'est les conséquences de sa qui
ont fait perdre en fait c'est les
conséquences ce qui a fait perdre la
partie
c'est la conséquence bon déjà c'est
l'ouverture entre guillemets ne pas être
rentré dans son schéma genre cavaliers
fils des cats et 5 et du coup tu
retournes dans le dans le benko donc ça
c'était première erreur
ou dans la baie noni et deuxième erreur
en fait bon plus tard mise à part les
petits trucs théorique avant mais c'est
de ne pas avoir compris qu'il fallait
absolument faire 5 pour libérer le fou
de cases blanches parce qu'après puis on
prend car l epr en cavalier prend dame
prend je ne parle pas de deux variantes
précise une nouvelle fois c'est pour
montrer mais ça permet de sortir le
football est peut-être qu'à valider
quatre et ça reste sympa pour les blancs
mais dans l'esprit c'était l'idée avoir
pendant assez longtemps qui n'a pas été
joué et est du coup elle n'a pas été
joué plus tard non plus j'en ris y
aurait pu faire dame c7
c'est parce qu'il aurait joué un coup
lambda et fois ci c'est changer les fous
et essayer de faire nul comme ça on va
dire qu'il ya eu les deux erreurs après
je sais pas benji la jouer une partie un
peu dans le style d'amy sow qui est 1300
i'm so fresh qui aurait pu jouer une
partie un peu comme ça il ya quand même
s'il un pion en un est là en gros si la
poussée 8 fou aussi ce blindage ses
pions de plus puis l'a quand même les
gars quand même enfin il a pas vus fou à
6 benji non plus fous des trois fois il
a quand même raté fou détroit aussi et
je sais pas 1500 normalement fou detroit
sa joie je sais pas exactement à quel
niveau sajoo c'est toujours difficile à
jouer parce qu'il ya des fulgurances et
des bons trucs des mauvais truc mais ok
genre là tu es juste dames 5 et
ça joue à 1200 rapide difficile pour un
de mes rencontres parce que je vois plus
embêtant rapide vous des 3500 tuera déjà
mais moi aussi pour 1500 ça me paraît
très dure a raté foot est roi pour moi
ouais il joue peut-être 1300 1350 donc
la 2e partie sort de façon qualifier
c'est sait rien de ces c'est pas un
match dans l'oeuf un sa matu perdre
ablain ya rien de st bo 3 il peut
égaliser et du coup je sais pas s'il ya
un départage je sais pas si un départage
dans ce truc là alors on dit sur food et
3 il y avait par haine des quatre alors
sur food et trois dames des 4 il y avait
foule prend à 6 pour répondre à la
question
non ce que je veux dire elle cache si
c'est qu'en fait c'est une phase de
poules et qu'en fait qu'ils gagnent ou
qu'ils perdent il est qualifié en quarts
de finale donc ça change strictement
rien en fait c'est parce pas grave de
perdre ça change rien en fait
vva
normalement il faut faire voir une
grande roue 4
c'est rien en fait ces matches-là faut
les prendre tranquille et moi je lui
avais conseillé de jouer aux quatre
personnes pour cette partie là pour un
peu brouillé les pistes
les jours un truc un peu différent
essayez de de nouvelles choses
histoire de voir de nouvelles positions
c'est toujours bien de ce sens ce truc
d'entraînement là quand tu es quand tu
sais que tu es qualif surtout à ce
niveau là pour voir un peu d'autres
choses
on va voir ce qu'il va faire dans mon
cas
la masse en laye
sur les exemples dispo quand sur youtube
dispo quand sur youtube bonne question
sûrement la semaine prochaine donc à
armageddon si je sais pas quel type
d'armageddon ils font mais en gros c'est
une partie où les blancs doivent gagner
absolument sans canule sejna puisse
qualifier parce que c'est reparti pas
encore une groupe aurait pu être
intéressante si mec s'est préparé pour
voir comme je vous disais en fait ces
matches-là faut vraiment les prendre
comme ça tranquillement en fait toute la
semaine et le son sur les finales n'ont
malheureusement ludo argent fait pas
toutes les semaines mais je vais essayer
d'en faire plus souvent à l'été
celle sur les autres langues en plus
j'ai des bons de toi et plein de gens
qui m'ont écrit pour me dire qu'il ya
que le que le contenu était bon
enfin j
je
et on va
le début de la deuxième partie
des quatre qui est rejouée des cinq fois
f4e six membres là c'est parfait
donc là le plan c3 c3 food et enfin que
trois cavaliers f3 fou des 3rocs
cavaliers 5 quel âge avait montré à
sartre cavaliers cinq ici direct ou fou
j'ai trois fous j'ai trouvé plus malin
l'idée sur france 3 c'est de faire alger
et là dessus un couvent alain cc3 ça si
on l'avait vu avec lui ensemble l'idée
sur fois ci c'est qu'il ya foule prend
1,6 kg et prend ainsi ses dames à quatre
échecs
quel dommage de pas tenter le piège rôle
à la sas a gagné il aurait suivi la
prépa le petit 1 3 le petit ces trois
fois 6 fou prend à six car il prend
assise damas quatre le petit piège
le petit piège carnet alors ça va
platement à la position c'est
mais ce petit piège cahier il fait mal à
ce niveau là ok mais là il ya damak
attend là y'a peut-être pions prends ça
peut encore fonctionner ces 3
caillé mais qui peut bien passer à ce
niveau à
mais bon ça ça doit aller aussi
'cependant et là la position elle va
elle va elle va complètement quand même
pour les blancs sur ces signes qu il n'y
avait pas quelque chose qui avait pas
rit avec damas quatre en fait qu'ils
étaient très forts
price le sait très tellement pris sur
ces trois fonds prend assise d'amd
barakat retarder cette dame prend roi
prend ok bon ça donnait pas je pensais
que ça pouvait donner quelque chose qui
n'est pas cavalier 17 mai n'en fout des
trois à foisches 4 fawcett
le problème en fait c'est que benji
fichiers il enfin il a compris en fait
que son fou allait être bloqué et oui
c'est intéressant parce que dans la
première partie en fait sarde il a perdu
parce que son fou est resté bloqué
derrière ses pions derrière sa structure
de pions et là on voit que les noirs ils
ont mis le fou en a six je pense qu'ils
trouvent d'amener ses trois essais de
doute ah je doute aussi bas qu'ils mais
je voulais juste dire fondamentalement
que ça a marché ou que ça marchait pas
mais on est d'accord on est 100 %
d'accord bâti sa trouvait pas tant
hacking je la vois pas quelqu'un qui
peut me dire l'horreur de l'aréna king
ce soir je la vois toujours pas bien
cinq six ans entre autres et non en tant
qu'acquis ali hafsi ça peut pas marcher
mais
mais bon là ça va la position c 7
ok là un truc intéressant ça peut
peut-être de prendre et de mettre une
tour anciens pour se mettre en face vous
reprocher si ça marche jamais enfin
quand un cavalier en effet c'est même
pas la peine de regarder
dams et 7
il veut quoi il veut qu'elle prend alors
là il ya plusieurs solutions il ya f4
aussi comme solution ok vous g3 ça peut
être cool
le truc c'est qu'il faut voir si sur
food & cie sont un bon coup c'est prend
des cinq gagné une pièce ya pas fou
prend des trois juste je rate peut-être
je regarde sans ordi à ok
cavalier processus d'un processus est
cédée par noah oui complètement
j'ai complètement raté aussi merci le
chat suis perdu dans la tactique c'est
vrai que dans ce sens là ça marche pas
très naturel de garder ce vis-à-vis
pendant longtemps les deux
pas le voir
c'est 3 700 kg/ha roi prend qui avait
fait un temps que cavaler couvre la case
h7 ça peut pas marcher
fini par faire c'est prendre des
français quatre normalement cavaliers
prend il peut jouer fou pranger 3,6 v
ouais du coup là l'autre peut faire
[ __ ] en g3 parce que sur h et il a pu
la tour sur la colonne et après c'est
prend des cats et prend des cas ça va
jouer contre l'option isolé à ce niveau
là pas d'inquiétude c'est hyper complexe
c'est pas sûr en plus qu'ils sachent
champions isoler benji fichiers c'est
pas sûr qu'il voit plus on prend pions
prend tour des huit jouer la colonne des
vraiment mettre une tour anciens
rapidement pour jouer la colonne ses
côtés blanc fallait pas reprendre neuf
n'ont toujours fait un quasiment
toujours reprendre vers le centre ça
faisait pas ce sens de reprendre de f
ici je pense était une grave erreur
là c'est bien c'est solide avantage noir
alors s'il fait c d e d oui mais si les
blancs fondé cbc ces avantages blanc
donc on va voir
au retour des 8 c'est pas mal aussi dans
le règne de coups parce que sur des
français 5a fou prend ses 4 donc ça me
prépare de la prise quoi
bref
dams et de yaka et b4 à ses chiens
autour des 8 faut peut-être tour c1
quand même tant pis pour jouer quand
même contre la dame noire et après
m'être la dame en e2 damas quatre sans
réfléchir damas cats est responsable
comme coût est fou de deux j'aime pas
par principe
ça maintient la dame ici et ça met pas
de pression et ça enlève le food une
belle diagonale
donc
du coup
continuons avec les blancs après sur
pions franc ça peut aller jusqu'aux
vitres qui va être une tour en c1 eux
cinq armées ok c'est cadeau qui va les
prendre cinq avaient prendre cinq points
cinq dames 35 qui comprend 1,5 to
reprend d un fou prend d un web à ce que
c'est ça joue pas ça joue pas 15 sans
non plus hein les gars à côté
côté noir 5 ça donne ce qu'on peut
prendre deux fois eux cinq près du mans
comme juif je vous rends pas compte mais
bon 5 ça m'a pas l'air d'être le coup de
l'année il va le voir
abbassi il ya deux pièces qui peuvent
prendre cinq voix l'a assez vu
et du coup d'après eux deux il ya plus
de clouage non c'était sûr que ça allait
voir c'est bien joué
par le pire mais je vois rien de mieux
je pense ajouterait ce sens benji
fichiers je pense à lou 13 14 cents pas
15 cents 13 14 ans elle sait pas
francis détroit encore mais jamais si je
vrai nom mais ça c'est sûr que c'est pas
joué après la ja patour ces
intermédiaires
ouais voilà des trois ça s'est jamais
joués on est d'accord maxime
mais bon après la finale avec un pion de
la position n'est qu'un pion de plus à
l'est pas clair s'il voit des trois
après la parole genre sarthe je pense
qu'il pourrait jouer de détroit par pure
envie de faire un coup intermédiaire
allez
un devoir jouer colonne c'est à présent
au tour c'est un tour ces trois tours
ici et par la suite avancé ses pions
on va
à
normalement
nier tranquille
dames 1 800 kumar louhans parce que ça
me rase dame prend des quatre mais bon
juste eu bouge la dame bamba
comment faut centraliser les tours et
avancer non elle n'est pas simple a
gagné encore n'allait pas
yeah
ouais
faire tour 17 ok peut-être tour des deux
tours d un autour c'est en fait faut
juste sortir les tours les maîtres est
avancé au tour des trois ans cueillir
là je pense ça va gagner pour les blancs
à ce niveau là il est plus facile quand
un plan clair et là le plan des blancs
c'est d'avancer je pense avec les noirs
c'est plus difficile à jouer à ce niveau
là normalement ça va être ça devrait
gagner les banquiers ils peuvent aussi
donner des pièces en un faire des trucs
comme ça mais semble vraiment qu'avec
les blancs c'est solide facile à jouer
tu doublé tour est là faut mettre la
marche avant maintenant et c'est plutôt
bien que ce soit au noir de jouer ici
bizarrement ce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de bons coups
comme dit achats reculent pattes
ce système est bon car elle a eu quatre
je m'attendais plus à sa mère est ce que
cavalia katia pas moyen de faire un truc
une tatie lecavalier ses seins il faut
faire attention quand même
c'est gagnant pour le match amical
contre carsen comme position ouais mais
faut encore la gagner un
on avait vu car le scène qui avait
défendu un pur loin quand maxime c'est
passe pas si facile à a terminé il faut
encore le faire mais salle alors quand
même bien gagnante mais bon c'est pas
dans le réel où tu es sûr de gagner à
100% on va dire ça comme ça donc
ouais acheter sa fille voilà c'est un
bon coup je suis d'accord avec toi cher
qu satellite l'ema du couloir et tu vas
en avoir besoin il peut y avoir une
tactique un jour tu prends un math h6 ça
aurait pu être un coût pour les noirs là
je sais pas comment il va avancer les
pions et ce qu'il va faire j'ai quatre f
3 m le kenyan f5 ou cf ici c'est pas
possible à étrangers 3
il a fait d'amr
donc ils préparent f3 c'est plutôt bien
joué je pense en tout cas que c'est son
idée après il faudra faire attention il
va y avoir un moment pas simple à gérer
on va voir
pareil toujours pour les noirs un coup
intéressant c'est peut être juste h61
pour temporiser même s'il ya des carrés
des f-5 qui peuvent arriver plus tard ou
quoi et jouer les affaiblissements à ce
niveau là en tout cas ça paraît sympa
cas et c'est sans actualité qu'on avait
vu un truc sur tours d2 qui avait eu
quatre tours des trois quais ces cinq
suspects perpète donc les blancs vont
devoir forcément quitter la colonne des
et peut-être il veut faire cavalier
aussi c'est ce qui peut pas avoir une
idée de marloux comme ça ça après j'ai
rarement ils savent pas faire à ce
niveau là en fait où tu as recèle la
tour et où tu veux faire nulle part
répétition alors après au pied on pourra
mettre la tour en c2 et ça va mais ça
peut être une idée faut faire attention
faut être vigilant à ce genre de choses
les perdre
mille deux cents annoncés sur un 1200 ça
va pas avoir lieu avec le lait blanc le
plomb est simple ça peut être tour des
deux cavaliers f3 en échange les pièces
on met la marche avant je pense juste
échangé des tours ça peut être un plan
en fait au lieu de dames 1
peut-être qu'un coup comme cavalier f3
était une idée hein ça peut être une
idée et sur damas si du coup on pouvait
faire tout reprendre et cette dame
prendre deux tours prend des huit matchs
j'ai passé une variante très à-propos
met donc damas inquiets ses cinq tours
d2
j'imagine qu'il va
rayon de quatre mais cinq à six volets
ils ont un peu de mal à faire ça
page 6 là c'est un coup intéressant avec
le truc c'est que sur cavaliers f5 ya
peut-être cavaliers detroit donc
peut-être remettre la dame en e2 en fait
très froid c'est bien aussi c'est dans
le règne de ce qu'il faut faire pour
faire quatre maîtres la marche avant la
dame
c'est pour ça le défend les pions
non c'est ça va voir comment les noirs
s'en sortent il a pas de plan avec les
noirs et se passe quoi quand on tombe à
zéro on perd la partie
damas six et de massy sa menace le pion
il faut juste le défendre alors deux
options invisible à 3 ou b 3 je pense
que ça a trois qui va être choisi
je pense
3 semble être un coût plus logique en
plus ça peut même préparé des p4 un jour
maintenant rb4 est une option je vais
pas parler ça laisse un peu de cavaliers
à 4/4 lycées 3 dans leur âge n'a pas
forcément envie cavaliers c6 ou là ça
c'est le genre de coups que j'aime pas
la position est stable les gagnantes et
la salle est où reprend tout reprend
tout reprend dame prend aidé à me prends
à 2 alors après il ya peut-être du jeu
avec dan des huit cavaliers set pour
aller faire maths et ça va peut-être
marcher mais je sais pas si c'était
volontaire
ça peut être très fort mais bon en
général
des positions gagnantes ne veut pas trop
s'envoyer là-dedans dame prend à deux
dames d83 cette cavale ie7 hockey et la
f6 et ça défend ses volontés vrai mais
bon ça généralement c'est pas trop le
genre de truc à faire alors ça peut
marcher
ça peut marcher mais
[Musique]
mais c'est hyper dangereux vos rêves
citoyenne orifices il va pas le voir là
ça va faire mal c'est sûr mais aussi cdu
aurait enfin dur en fait faut voir que
tu dois défendre sa g 8 et du voulu va
faire h5 dame g8 3,6 damache huit mois
j'ai cinq dames prendrait sept ça va
mater renon la variante elle est pas mal
là c'est juste que c'est pas c'est pas
généralement ce que tu cherches à faire
dans cette position là mais ça suffit ça
passe 1,6 à gagne ça gagne 1,6 et
chauvin après il ya une dame en a 2 faut
défendre la casse g8 mais c'est
difficile de comprendre que c'est la
dame qui doit revenir défendre
à ce niveau ça doit
c'est vrai invisible f6 il y aurait
d'autres possibles dans le truc c'est
qu'il va faire h5 en fait tu aurais pas
h5 possible m6 serait plus visible
voilà c'est ce que j'allais dire
forcément il fait h5 et yamaha temps 3
forcément à bala il ya d'amsterdam il va
pas le voir il va pas le voir s'il l'a
vu bon voilà c'est perdu les amis c'est
dommage que ce thème attend d'eux
c'était damage suis 3g cinq dames g7
matt terrible ouais c'est vraiment
terrible
la cera
rible le dame prend à vii 1 comprend
aussi le seimat en deux j'avais
d'arachide dame g7 pour après ça va
c'est pas un match important mais ça
c'est choquant attend d'eux quand même
dommage de rater
maintenant ça
préhensibles en fait la vente de
cavaliers celle ci s'était tellement
complexes et dames enfin j'ai pas assez
incompréhensible c'est incompréhensible
après ça comprend aussi parce que la
vente est vraiment complexe et bien joué
mais meiway damache 8 faut être dans ma
chute échec seule case roi g5 et dames
sept matches
9-7 en fait il a dû penser qu'ils
avaient d'apprendre dame g6 matteau
prochain elle a juste oublié la dame en
a deux après l'autre l'a pas vu tout de
suite hein l'autre l'a pas
bien de temps à jouer dans le premier
cercle les deux joueurs ont pas vu où il
a mis dix secondes à jouer donc il
n'avait pas vu de base dame prend 1,7
après la dame est arrivée là finit par
le voir façon s'il avait vu d'un premier
set loti lors ff6 donc et deux joueurs
oublier la dame et du cou et du coup ça
gagne et complexe
bon après c'est pas grave
vous disais ce n'était pas un match
ultra ultra important l'important ça à
partir des quarts y'a pas d'élimination
il sait il s'est rien passé les gains
qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils perdent y avait
il n'y a pas de différence
y'a pas ya aucune différence les gars
donc pas de deux mille 2000 doit oui
mais bon enfin c'est cher ça c'est leur
live hier pour le tournoi il n'y a pas
de 2000 $ ses 1500 euros pour pour
l'heure ça c'est cesser leur leurs
revenus quoi c'est ça les regarde ce
qu'il y a une chair par là que pour nous
en tant que supporters ça change rien
c'est la stricte d'invicibilité ok mais
bon cgc à l'avant ce que tu que tu peux
perdre donc c'est rien c'est pour une
association dis pas ça passe
une autre association qui va avoir les
deux mille dollars chimie s'est pas
alors l'argent il disparaît pas en fait
à une association qui a pas les avoir
été une autre association qui va les
avoir pas la moitié de l'argent qui est
pour l'association la moitié pour les
joueurs s'est partagé en deux il ya deux
cent mille de prix pour les joueurs et
deux cent mille pour les associations
messi a pas 2000 qui va une association
il en va à une autre
dit ça va ça va prochain match ça va
mieux se passer s'est c'est après là que
ça devient important est qu'on va être
chaud faut être chaud il faut être chaud
pour les matches qui comptent et il faut
gagner les matches qui comptent les amis
ah mais c'est rien les gars là
y'a pas y'a pas de gravité sur toutes
les parties étaient pas mal joué c'est
juste dommage je peux avoir fait d'un
match 8 dames g7 y avait ma temps 2 mais
bon sait rien bon alors les gars et ce
constante l'aréna à 1h du mat où on se
fait un tft où on attend le début de la
reina et on part en tft après comment on
se fait ça ok si on se sente l'aréna du
coup je vais je vais vous mettre
quelques petits clips
je vais changer le titre et on voit si
ça se passe mal au début on parenté fc
direct
du coup je
l'ips le temps de récup et j'arrive donc
je change de stream
on va leur être sur mon stream perso et
on se retrouve tout de suite a tout de
suite les gars